am tag als der präsident der ukraine in
münchen die bühne betritt gerät sein
innenminister im osten des landes unter
granatenbeschuss
am tag als sich der westen konkretes
aussenminister shah thq ihren
pro-russische separatisten im donbass
zivilisten es wirkt das würde russland
die bühne bereiten für einen krieg
die welt muss jetzt nach die ganze welt
nicht nur wir werden unser land
verteidigen ob mit oder ohne unsere
partner
das richtet sich gegen deutschland die
ukraine fühlt sich im stich gelassen
nach wie vor die lenz rede ist die
ernüchternde bilanz einer woche wie sie
die deutsche außenpolitik kaum je erlebt
hat sie beginnt ende vergangener woche
in der ost wo die außenministerin
unterwegs ist der bagger fährt dort von
us erkenntnissen eine russische invasion
in der ukraine stehe unmittelbar bevor
am samstag vollzieht sie was berlin bis
dahin unbedingt vermeiden wollte der
oxid botschaftspersonal aus kiew ab das
auswärtige amt spricht außerdem eine
reisewarnung für die ukraine aus
berliner könnten was sich nicht mehr
erkennen lässt was bundeskanzler scholz
am montag nach kiew kommt hatte den
bedrohten land wenig anzubieten ein
kredit über 150 millionen euro dabei
muss die ukraine und hat zuvor allein
500 millionen an garantien bereitstellen
damit der luftverkehr nicht
zusammenbricht scholz will auch keine
waffen liefern die atmosphäre war heißt
es von ukrainischer seite 30 wir sind
natürlich nach wie vor enttäuscht dass
das dass dieser zurückhaltung hier
vorherrscht wir berufen uns auf die
uno-charta und auf das recht auf
selbstverteidigung die deutsche
bundesregierung beruft sich auf ihre
eigenen richtlinien die keine rechtliche
bindung haben und die mit finger
schnipsen und mit einer politischen
entscheidung
innerhalb von wenigen minuten geändert
werden muss einen tag später fliegt lot
of moscow putin kündigt einen teilabzug
der truppen an nach der pkw der
champagner in corona abstand als gäbe es
ein bisschen entspannung doch westliche
geheimdienste sehen keine verringerung
sondern eine verstärkung der truppen
putin serviert eine zermürbungstaktik
man versucht die ukraine innenpolitisch
unter druck zu setzen dass sie
beschäftigt ist mit dem konflikt und
sich nicht innenpolitisch reformieren
kann weiter und der westen in eine art
von ukraine müdigkeit kommt wo man
irgendwann mal sagt dass man sich mit
diesem thema eigentlich nicht mehr
beschäftigen will und man so über lange
frist von eskalation deeskalation zu
einer neuen art von von setting kommt
dass russlands forderungen nicht formal
entgegenkommt aber de facto weit
entgegenkommt am donnerstag im bundestag
gibt es dagegen eine merkwürdige allianz
der putin verteidiger ganz rechts und
ganz links im plenum sind sie sich einig
das problem soll nicht russlands
truppenaufmarsch sondern die usa
die regierung verlässt sich gern auf
informationen der us geheimdienste ich
mich nicht wie sie meint den irak krieg
und die stümperhaft gefälschten
dokumente die damals den einmarsch
rechtfertigen sollten aber was hat das
mit heute zu tun
nichts sagt der militärexperte anthony
cordesman weil diesmal alles offen
zutage liege
der unterschied zum iran
es gibt einen russischen aufmarsch in
belarus und im osten
und wir wissen von diesem vorgehen
russlands nicht allein durch
das ist etwas völlig anderes und kann
nicht so einfach politisiert werden wie
damals beim irak
zurück in münchen die sorge um die
deutschen in der ukraine ist am samstag
so groß geworden dass die
außenministerin die reißleine zieht die
deutschen sollten das land jetzt
verlassen für die ukraine dagegen hat
die bundesregierung nach wie vor nicht
viele anzubieten
wir brauchen eine ich noch gewonnen
verteidigungs verteidigungswaffen weil
mit cookies und können wir nicht unsere
landwirte hingegen eine der mächtigsten
armeen der welt am ende einer woche mit
beispielloser krisendiplomatie fordert
scholz die grenzen eines landes müssten
akzeptiert werden zur sicherheit aller
am gleichen tag leitet putin ein manöver
mit
atomwaffenfähige raketen
[Musik]